[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un venue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire que je suis absolument ravi
de retrouver à au bout de deux mois
d'enregistrement à domicile confinement
oblige pour une émission aujourd'hui
consacré au monde d'après c'est le sujet
de conversation numéro un alors va-t-il
falloir produire plus travailler
davantage s'affranchir de certaines
règles sociales ou environnementales et
réduire les déficits que l'on a creusé
comme jamais pour rattraper le temps
perdu et surtout l'argent perdu éviter
la catastrophe qui se profile
ou bien faut-il produire moins consommer
- planifier davantage revaloriser
l'intervention publique et la protection
sociale ne plus avoir peur des déficits
publics et respecter davantage
l'environnement
sinon ce sera la catastrophe pour en
débattre nous avons invité françois
asselin président de la ceppm la
confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises qui fédère 150 mille pme
représentant 3 millions de salariés
vous êtes vous-même patron d'une
entreprise du bâtiment
le monde d'après selon vous il devra
être plus productifs ou moins productifs
françois asselin frau décalé vous savez
moi j'ai comme diplô me pme +27 année
donc j'ai toujours connu l'année
suivante où je devais être meilleure que
l'année précédente à savoir produire
mieux augmenter la qualité et ne jamais
entre guillemets sortir du marché c'est
à dire toujours avoir des prix comptera
donc la productivité vous savez c'est un
tout et je ne vois pas pourquoi demain
le monde ce serait différent de celui
d'aujourd'hui
christophe ramaux économiste membre du
collectif des économistes atterrés
depuis son lancement 2011 lavier
également été l'un des initiateurs de
l'appel pour sortir de la pensée unique
en 1996 on en reparle encore aujourd'hui
de sortir de la pensée unique êtes
l'auteur de l'état social pour sortir du
chaos néolibérale paru chez fayard dans
la collection mille et une nuits le
monde d'après vous devra-t-il être plus
productifs ou moins productifs
christophe ramaux écoutez je pense qu'il
faut vraiment vont changer de modèle il
est plus que temps
mais pour répondre directement la
question à vous poser
je pense qu'il ya lieu d'augmenter
certaines productions
incontestablement on a des besoins
énormes besoins satisfaits aujourd'hui
en matière de santé ou as venir de
logements et la crise en cours entre est
qualifié d effroyables en matière de
logement donc il ya des besoins
satisfaits en matière de logement ça
concerne le secteur du btp dans lequel
travaille chez ascain il ya des besoins
insatisfaits pour répondre aux besoins
écologiques ne vient pas à l'occasion sa
route il ya certaines productions bien
entendu qui sont qu'il convient de
réduire les activités financières n'ont
pas été les plus utiles dans la crise en
cours et je pense que de façon générale
il y a lieu de réduire la domination le
poids excessif de la finance sur de
grandes entreprises et partant
d'ailleurs sur leurs sous traitants que
sont les pme
on n'a peut-être pas besoin compte tenu
des défis environnementaux qui sont
majeurs de produire toujours plus de suv
donc il ya certaines productions qu'il
convient de réduire mais globalement
j'insiste vois pas ce que je vais vous
surprendre ceux qui ont du talent et je
pense que je ne suis pas du tout en
faveur des thèses de la décroissance et
c c'est-à-dire que quand on compte il
faut augmenter la production du pib dans
son bien il ya souvent une un tir aux
pigeons c'est haut la main contre le big
buck's moi je défend ardemment ce cet
indicateur qui est le pib pourquoi parce
que c'est à la fois les productions par
contre ce qui est très important c'est
qu'elle production privilégie donc il
est donc ça bien entendu gardé pas
important mais c'est aussi les revenus
on arrive où la transaction si les
calculs et pb on arrive exactement mêmes
chiffres
c'est merveilleux production contenu les
salaires les profits et puis la demande
et donc si vous baissez la production
d'art regarder c'est ce qu'on est en ce
moment en ce moment on a une baisse
terril du revenu en france mais comme
dans plein d'autres deux pays à
l'échelle mondiale il faut savoir que la
crise en cours
ça va se traduire selon le programme
alimentaire mondial pam par un
doublement mains de gens qui risquent
mère de famille donc comment dire moi je
ne suis pas pour baisser les rangs du
champion baisser les revenus de certains
donc réduire les inégalités
mais globalement je pense qu'il ya
d'immenses besoins insatisfaits
donc l'enjeu c'est pas baisser la
production c'est de réorienter
françois cela est-ce qu'il va falloir
travailler plus ou est-ce qu'il va
falloir travailler moi ça sera aussi on
en parle beaucoup on allemand est
travaillée forcément on se dit après
tout ça pourrait continuer comme ça oui
mais malheureusement vous savez le champ
de la cigale se termine toujours mal et
ça finit par un couac
donc on est nous patrons de pme plutôt
sur des choses relativement simple et
clair c'est à dire que la dette n'est
tout sauf virtuel et tous les des
ornières que nous sommes en train de
creuser un moment ou un autre il faudra
bien les combler et pour les combler eh
bien il faut globalement créer de la
richesse et pour créer des richesses et
bien il faut créer de l'activité du
travail et si on regarde par exemple
alors là je m'adresse un petit peu à
l'économiste mais à partir des années
2000 lorsque la france a fait le choix
de contingenter finalement l'activité
avec les 35 heures on a eu à côté de
nous un autre exemple les mâles
l'allemagne qui n'est pas rentré dans
cette va dire courbe déflationniste du
travail comme nous l'avons fait nous à
partir des années 2000 avec les 35
heures alors finalement on s'aperçoit ou
du coup qu'en france on travaille
annuellement un petit peu plus de 1600
heures et que nous sommes dans
l'ensemble de l'espace européen encore
un pays qui travaille finalement un peu
moins que les autres
or et bien il y avait une décision qui
avait fait beaucoup de qui avait
beaucoup de succès aussi bien du côté
des employeurs que du côté des salariés
c'est lorsque c'était du temps de la
présidence de nicolas sarkozy ou les
heures supplémentaires était nette de
taxes et nets d'impôts mais net de taxes
et nets d'impôts pour les salariés et
net de dax pour les employeurs aussi de
charges patronales ce qui faisait que la
fameuse maxime travaillait plus pour
gagner plus
et bien finalement fonctionné très bien
et c'est comme ça effectivement qu'on
développe de la richesse alors attention
à l'heure actuelle au moment où je vous
parle on n'est absolument pas dans cette
situation parce que là pour l'instant
nous sommes en mouvement
de travail il avant de retrouver une
pleine activité il va falloir passer
cette fichue période qui finalement est
encore un petit peu longue devant nous
quel timbre amende et attrapes monsieur
françois hénin beaumont dire quelque
part ne décevez c'est à vous vous tenez
un discours quand même quelle est
exactement la même il ya six mois il ya
un an et ses anciens c'est toujours la
même rengaine
vous pouvez pas sérieusement dire que la
crise actuelle ou que la crise de 2008
c'est lié aux 35 heures vous pouvez pas
vous pouvez pas un sou tenir sur la
registre je suis sûr que intimement vous
ne pouvez pas soutenir cela donc une
petite parenthèse travail le temps de
travail quand on croit aux contes le
temps partiel qui est beaucoup plus
développée en allemagne et dans les pays
nordiques et bien on s'aperçoit que en
france od où les oules est plutôt dans
la moyenne
donc ya pas il n'y a pas lieu par contre
on a moins de temps partiel c'est plutôt
ce faut plutôt s'en faut plutôt sans eau
sont satisfaits mais comme vous l'avez
vous rennes soutenu à l'heure actuelle
vous avez bien compris que les
entreprises il vous avez été parmi les
premiers à demander et vous avez raison
vous avez biberonné à la dépense
publique et c'est très bien ainsi
vous êtes en train de bill dans votre
chair que niveau dans des économies
mixte dans lequel ya du privé et c'est
très bien qu'il y ait du privé même si
le mode de fonctionnement des grandes
entreprises doit être accueillant remis
en cause la domination de la finance qui
écrase les pme s'est bien passé pour le
pour le savoir vous êtes en situation de
frais tant de sérogroupe qui
délocalisent qui selon une logique de
rentabilité actionnariale complètement
comment dire comme thème quand comme
étant à la fois injuste socialement et
inefficace d'un pôle d'économie qui
désarme y compris le tissu industriel de
notre pays mais pour revenir l'inconnu
sujet de la commande hier 2 de la
dépense plus qu'on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'y revenir
je pense qu'il faut cibler le 10 sport
qui consiste à dire on a deux grands
malheurs en france c'est la dépense
publique et les 35 heures ça je pense
que ce discours là
cette petite rengaine là ça ne passe
plus ça ne passe plus vous l'avez vous
même noté aujourd'hui la question qui se
pose
on a des centaines de millions à près de
cinq cent mille emplois qui sont en
train d'être détruit on a on a plein
d'autres qui passent ça passe notamment
par le fait qu'il ya plein en fait de
contrats précaires qui ne sont pas
renouvelés
mais dont condamne manoeuvre disponibles
donc le jeu bien entendu c'est surtout
pas favorisé les heures supplémentaires
c'est de permettre à ceux qui sont sans
emploi d'avoir un bon point c'est comme
ça le principal le principal enjeu et
d'autre part sur la dépense mais on y
reviendra enfin qu'il faut cesser un à
diane tell public c'est comme la dette
privée
vous êtes bien placé pour savoir il ya
plein d'entreprises aujourd'hui qu'ils
vont voir au niveau des pauvres exposés
bien entendu iliad est en soi c'est pas
un mal d'accord c'est une fantastique
invention d'humanité il peut y avoir des
excès de tête mais ce qui est valable
pour le privé est valable pour le public
ce qui est très important ce qui est
très important pour que les aides
publiques soient soutenables et
aujourd'hui elle sauve sultanat compte
tenu des taux d'intérêt très bas ce qui
est très important c'est qu'ils
effectivement c'est que cela permet de
relancer de l'activité et donc qui vont
permettre y compris de pouvoir payer
sans aucun problème les dettes futures
le japon est à plus de 200 consent de
dette publique depuis des années ça me
pose aucun problème est trop important
les pays qui avant la crise en cours
avec les dettes est plus faible et est
pas du tout les pays qui avaient un
niveau d'emplois publics plus faire il
faut savoir qu'en france la part de
l'emploi public c'est à peu près 20%
dans le poids total
c'est un chiffre stable depuis 40 ans
gars les pays qui sont ils ou la suède
le danemark
ils sont après 30 % ils sont pas plus
mal et la dette publique dans ces pays
là est plus faible qu'en france
n'obtient pas de lien entre entremont
employés et d'un public mais vraiment ce
que je pense que ce discours sur le
thème à la la la la la la
comment dire il faut à tout prix pour
nous n il faut que l'état dépense des
milliards je pense que c'était légitime
pour sauver les entreprises
et puis ensuite dire eh bien l'état doit
faire de l'austérité va former
suffisamment c'est pas possible
vous avez bien compris qu'on avance mais
le plus d'argent pour les hôpitaux pour
l'éducation 26 ans de retard sur munich
écoutez vous vous êtes bien conscient
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une période
tout à fait que nos classes tout ce que
nous vivons bien évidemment s'il n'a pas
le soutien de l'état ne serait ce que
pour les salariés du secteur marchand
qui sont pris largement qui sont portées
par le chômage partiel
et s'il n'est pas le soutien au secteur
marchand ou personne morale du secteur
marchand que sont les entreprises et
parmi elles principalement les pme les
tpe et bien l'espoir de rebondir
sera complètement nul donc je ne remets
je remet absolument pas en cause
l'implication et l'endettement massif
actuel de l'êta ont pour éviter le nom
rebonds dont on a besoin bien évidemment
de cet état qui soutient son économie
mais met à vous écouter
un état qui entre guillemets au fil des
ans en équilibre pas son budget
finalement c'est pas important c'est à
dire que la dette
globalement on peut toujours y aller on
a droit de tirage sachant qu'un jour les
taux que vous avez cités qui sont
effectivement très bas et aujourd'hui
s'endetter finalement elle s'est
complètement paradoxal c'est s'enrichir
1 eh bien eh bien si jamais demain les
taux augmentent
est ce que ça sera pas un problème
systémique pour notre pays vous avez
cité le japon la différence me
semble-t-il je suis pas économiste mais
entre le japon et la france c'est que la
dette appartient aux japonais 1 or en
france une grande partie de la dette je
crois les deux tiers appartiennent et
bien à des pays extérieurs à la france
d'après vous est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
problème à terme de souveraineté tout
simplement parce que nos banquiers sont
extérieurs à notre pays
mais comme maire je suis là quand pompe
aux sinus comme maire je suis d'accord
avec vous de souci de souveraineté
je pense que c'est un très grand jour
effectivement de retrouver une certaine
forme de souveraineté nationale au toute
chose je pense que c'est un véritable
enjeu est donc si vous me dites que ça
serait mieux de nationaliser la ned et
puis pourquoi pas mais ça changerait
fondamentalement rien il faut savoir que
comment dire vous savez que vous êtes
bien placé vous êtes chef d'entreprise
vous savez comme moi que un chef
d'entreprise la première chose qui fait
quand y créer une entreprise il n'est
possible ligne de trésorerie avec sa
banque
et puis il emprunte pour acheter les
équipements des bâtiments etc
quand la tête vous savez il ya quand la
tête des entreprises s'y recolle au
besoin qu'on me difficile par dans les
entreprises quand le besoin de
financement les entreprises baissent
c'est une catastrophe pour l'économie
c'est ce qu'on appelle le déficit d
entreprise server 2009 en 2009 le besoin
de financement les entreprises a baissé
de ses biens c'est génial le déficit des
entreprises amies féministes une
catastrophe ça voulait dire qu'elles
investissent et moi donc ce qui est
valable pour une entreprise sur le fait
que
l'entreprise puissent s'endetter pour
lancer les activités
c'est là pour le public la dette les
déficits c'est comme le chocolat ça
permet de lancer les activités là où
jusqu'à la crue a éventuellement avec
vous c'est bien entendu il peut y avoir
des excès de chocolat mais comment dire
c'est assez étonnant que les libéraux ne
cesse en quelque sorte d' espérer qu'un
jour il ya une hausse des taux d'intérêt
pour qu'il puisse enfin dire arnal à la
dette c'est une catastrophe énorme et
comment dire que les taux d'intérêt sont
très bas et je vous assure qu'ils vont
le rester il suffit que les banques
centrales interviennent en sorte
qu'elles sont obligées de faire
donc elles vont le rester et la dette
publique comment dire c'est pas trés
c'est pas très grave
c'est bien ça serait bien de l'abaisser
mais quand dire c'est pas trés
marcillacois d'abord c'est il faut
cesser de dire c'est un fardeau ou non
tout ça chez certains contestataires
parfois où est ce que je dis donc je ne
partage pas ce point de vue mais c'est
pas un fardeau la france l'année
dernière où les pays 40 milliards
d'intérêts ce à présent 2 % du pib
durant les trente glorieuses on était à
1 1 5% du pib de paiement des taux
d'intérêt ce n'est pas ce n'est pas ceux
ci devant moi qu'est ce qu'on a fait
pour payer ces 40 milliards et pour
payer en plus 100 milliards de capital
qui arrivait à échéance
l'explication qui arrive à échéance le
28 et aujourd'hui est d'environ sept
heures et bien qu est ce qu a fait l
agence france trésor et bien emprunté
200 milliards à peu près pour payer les
40 milliards d'intérêts pour payer les
100 milliards de capital qu'il fallait
renoncer
et puis en plus ça il y avait le déficit
primaire parce qu'il ya une différence
quand même autre la dette publique et la
dette privée
autre aménagement des mortels à la fin
de sa vie il obligé d'avoir remboursé sa
dette
une entreprise elle peut faire en partie
couvert sa dette mais classe b to c
privée donc c'est plus fragiles l'état
mais depuis les états bonnaire mais
depuis des lustres et dans tous les pays
du monde
qu'est ce qu'ils font il faut courir
leur dette c'est à dire qu'ils en 33 ans
c'est parce qu'ils sont immortels et
c'est pas chez nous là où ça devient
gênant
bien entendu c'est dans la tête ne vient
pas souhaitable mais la banlieue en
absolument pas ce problème de
soutenabilité l'enjeu je suis sûr vous
serez les premiers que loge aujourd'hui
c'est que l'économie ne s'effondre pas
et l'enjeu de mon point de vue c'est non
seulement dans les interventions
publiques sous forme de déficit et de
dette pour relancer l'économie ont pris
de rides
mais l'enjeu aussi c'est de conduire de
saisir cette occasion qu'on n'a pas
saisi en 2008 pour changer le domaine
changer de modèle ça veut dire quoi ça
ne pas dire en finir avec l'économie
privée s'est terminée ce ton là bien
entendu on a quitté le 20e siècle
ça veut dire que il faut rompre avec ce
qu'on appelle le néolibéralisme la
finance libéralisée
j'étouffe des entreprises s'est tous
fait logique productive le le libre
échange il faut remettre des règles du
commerce international
l'homme l'a vu sur la question d'un
produit chimique test des masques
étaient rares et puis austérité
salariale
parce que s'ils ont pris cette hostilité
qui a creusé des dettes un modèle
néolibéral c'est au fait de l'austérité
qui ont dit aux gens il faut quand même
continuer à dépenser pour soutenir
l'activité des entreprises privées donc
en été nous mais ce qui a beaucoup
augmenté ces dernières années
c'est pas simplement les dettes
publiques à cause du néolibéralisme
c'est aussi les dates clés des ménages
et des entreprises
en france la dette des entreprises vous
le savez bien voir a beaucoup monté ces
dernières années j'aime pour un françois
star premièrement est-ce qu'il faut
effectivement mettre fin à la stérilité
salariale beaucoup l'espèrent réduire
les échanges internationaux comme le
suggère votre interlocuteur alors moi je
pense si vous laissez c'est d'abord je
je je rejoins monsieur ramos sur la
deuxième partie de son développement sur
la dette je suis un petit peu plus
réservé parce que tout dépend pour quoi
on s'endette en ce moment par exemple
ceux qui font des prêts garantis par
l'état
eh bien ils s'endettent pour assurer
leurs frais de fonctionnement
lorsqu on s'endette pour faire de
l'investissement il me semble c'est une
dette beaucoup plus vertueuses que c'en
était tout simplement pas pour combler
un déficit social par exemple au niveau
de l'état il me semble que l'état depuis
des années l'état français c'est plutôt
endettés pour tout simplement nourrir la
machine de fonctionnement plutôt que
d'investir si vous voulez et et femmes
ont écouté je suis pas économiste vous
l'êtes
on a droit d'avoir chacun son point de
vue au niveau l'entreprise je peux vous
dire que l'endettement peut être aussi
mortelles comme pour un particulier et
bien souvent quand le banquier commence
à vous dire ben écoutez vous êtes trop
endettés ça veut dire que le coup
d'après votre caddie trésorerie il va
être réduit et là vous risquez d'avoir
une machine qui s'arrête donc bien
évidemment nous chefs d'entreprise de
pme
on a les urines
et sur notre endettement parce qu'on
sait que si on va trop loin
l'épicier on traverse une période
difficile comme celle ci est bien on est
cuit donc on est plutôt dans une optique
de jouer le long terme pour jouer la
pérennité il vient dans les bonnes
années
il faut faire attention à l'argent que
rentrer l'entreprise et garder quelques
noisettes de côté
concernant les salaires vous savez quand
on est patron pme où vit avec ses
salariés
on les voit tous les jours ils nous
voient grandir en tant que chef
d'entreprise quand on les accompagne
depuis de nombreuses années et nous
aussi on les voit grandir dans
l'entreprise lorsqu'on les prend dès
l'apprentissage
on aimerait bien souvent les récompenses
et mieux que nous pouvons le faire
pourquoi parce que c'est le client qui
finalement met la pression sur
l'entreprise
on a deux obligations de résultat
lorsque nous sommes chef d'entreprise on
doit une obligation résultat vis-à-vis
de son client pour servir une commande
sur laquelle est bien il faut assurer ce
qu'on a vendu en qualité quantité en
délais et en même temps on a une
obligation vis-à-vis de son entreprise
où il faut équilibrer les recettes et
les dépenses
et là bien évidemment la partie humaine
les salaires les hommes c'est très
important et qu'on ne vous fait pas
beaucoup de marge
eh bien les récompenses et ça vient tout
de suite compliqué regardez par exemple
l'exemple de la prime que propose le
gouvernement qu'on appelle la prima
compte mais c'est plutôt la prime patron
parce que c'est c'est le chef
d'entreprise qui décide ou pas de la
donner eh bien on aimerait tellement
beaucoup d'entreprises aimerait
tellement pouvoir l'a versé à ceux de
nos collaborateurs qui ont continué à
travailler pendant cette période de
confinement mais lorsque votre modèle
économique est en train de tourner à
l'envers
à savoir que vos recettes n'équilibre
pas vos dépenses eh bien vous ne pouvez
pas les récompenser et donc vouloir
augmenter les salaires
et bien c'est tout simplement pouvoir
augmenter entre guillemets la marche des
entreprises et ce que nous avons tout le
temps réclamé à la cpmc que l'argent qui
reste dans l'entreprise
et bien soit bénéficiaire d'un niveau de
fiscalité inférieur par rapport à
l'argent qui sort de l'entreprise
je parle entre autres des dividendes 1
c'est à dire que ça permettrait de
muscler et de type de capitaliser les
petites entreprises
alors bien évidemment il faudrait
plusieurs années mais ça permettrait
en tout cas de faire partager la
richesse créée au plus grand nombre et
en priorité par les collaborateurs et
dernière question et plus de
protectionnisme
- des changes internationaux plus de
souveraineté
vous savez on a souvent l'habitude de
dire à la ces pme la concurrence elle
est faite pour les petits quand plus
vous grossissez bien plus vous êtes en
position effectivement de monopole 1 et
donc la concurrence et elle existe mais
c'est à une échelle mondiale
et lorsque sur certains marchés vous
commencez à avoir une position dominante
même si vous êtes quelques acteurs et
bien c'est vous qui décidez à la place
de et finalement lorsque les états
mettent en place par exemple des
systèmes contraignant eh bien il est
parfois dix fois plus contraignant pour
la petite entreprise que pour la grande
entreprise parce que la grande
entreprise allait les moyens de gérer ce
système normatif système contraignant ce
que la petite entreprise n'a pas là et
donc il faut toujours trouver le juste
équilibre entre ouvrir grand les portes
du libéralisme qui finalement visqueux
bien évidemment d'avoir comme première
miti victimes les plus faibles à savoir
les petites entreprises
il y aura toujours les grands gagnants
qui sont déjà les grands conglomérats
qui finalement joue sur la planète
entière alors que nous on joue souvent
sur notre région sur notre département
parfois sur l'autre pays quelquefois un
tout petit peu à l'export mais c'est
très modeste donc on a effectivement une
économie qui s'est extrêmement
financiarisé au fil des ans surtout ces
dernières années on a vu la crise de
2008 qui finalement était une crise
entre guillemets en ce qui nous concerne
qui nous échapper complètement parce que
pour moi ce n'était pas une crise du
vrai travail
c'était une crise d'une économie qui
s'était financiarisé une sorte de casino
fou qui reposait sur rien et dont nous
avons été les premières victimes
donc nous sommes on était stupéfaits 1
et finalement tous les états sont venus
au secours de ceux là même qui ont créé
ces je veux dire ces dérives quoi du
marché donc effectivement nous sommes
pour le libre le
bré change parce que vous savez les
échanges c'est vieux comme le monde
1 les hommes ont commencé par le troc
maintenant il ya l'argent pour aider aux
échanges mais ça mérite d'être régulé
bien évidemment et c'est peut-être et je
l'espère une des leçons que nous
devrions tirer de ce qui s'est passé en
2008 et en 2009 et de ce qui est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui encore
voilà dominique armand christophe vous
vous pensez qu'il faut moins d'échangés
internationaux quand vous parlez de de
récupérer une part de souveraineté
d'introduire du protectionnisme vous
avez proposé dans le sens de
commentaires de monsieur monsieur st
je suis vraiment mais c'est pas une
concession de forme je suis intimement
convaincu que la concurrence que
l'initiative privée ça a du bon
par contre je suis en quelque sorte pour
une économie républicaine la république
ça tient à la fois par des libertés
individuelles par du jeu de libertés
individuelles qui sont nécessaires et
puis ça tient aussi par le suffrage
universel des lois l'état qui permettent
à la société est bien de te lien comme
société d'accord bon eh bien c'est
exactement une chose qui je pense qu'on
me dit qu'il faut changer de modèle que
nous devons dupliquer à l'échelle
économique c'est reconstruire une
économie républicaine qui réhabilite en
quelque sorte la réalité en fait de nos
économies nous vivons dans d économie
mixte d économie mixte ça veut dire quoi
la raison pour laquelle de soufre ou
celui moi je termine sur ce point je
pense que la raison pour laquelle de
sucre ou au fond c'est parce que de la
suivante à 4,40 m nous avons alors c'est
quoi une cd réalité27 economics nous
avons bien entendu des entreprises
privées y compris les pme et à la suite
de ce que vous avez dit je me rejoint en
partie
je pense qu'il est très important de
distinguer ce qu'on appelle des pme et
puis les grandes entreprises même s'il
ya des nuances aussi entre certaines pme
qui sont gérés parfois casse
autocratique députés ont dû parfois
qu'ils sont bien gérées et certaines
grandes entreprises qui permet de gérer
les crises mais le loden qui s'est
imposée pour les grandes entreprises
je pense que vous en conviendrez si vous
avez évoqué nous mêmes c'est le modèle
de la firme actionnariat
quand même c'est vrai qu'elle est lui
ans entre les entreprises du cac 40 mais
ce modèle de la firme actionnariat c'est
un modèle qui s'appuie sur l'idée que la
conduire la finalité de l'entreprise
c'est d'abord et avant tout de produire
des revenus pour les actionnaires sous
forme de dividendes ou ce fort pire
encore de rachat d'actions d'un tiers
des entreprises utilisent une partie de
ses ressources de ses profits pour
racheter ses propres actions les
déchirer pour faire voter le court on
voit bien qu'il pense a détruit la du
capital et donc ces grandes firmes pour
faire toujours plus de revenus pour les
actionnaires qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
elles se sont appuyées sur le libre
échange sur la possibilité pour elle et
sa vie d'antan du dpni opaque c'est la
bérézina tu la possibilité de dire ben
tiens pour produire tel ou tel composant
je vais mettre en concurrence deux ou
trois établissements que j'ai à travers
le monde
ils sont attelés boutique du commerce
mondial c'est du commerce intra fiable
c'est des commerces internes fuyant avec
les firmes qui fixe à bien les prix un
dock avec possibilité de localiser les
activités ici et la détention affirmé
deux pics y compris fiscale et donc sur
cette base là les grandes firmes four du
dumping fiscal mais aussi d'un ping
sociales et bien entendu mais que les
pme dans un étau absolument effroyable
là puisque pour faire plus pour donner
plus d'argent ne comprit pas actionnaire
qu'est ce qu'une fête où on dit au début
vous êtes bien placé pour savoir à quel
point les pme sont souvent écrasées par
comment dire par leurs parents dans
leurs dents et je dirais qu'il faut
comme des il faut sortir de l'idée que
l'essentiel de l'économie
c'est que des pme en france tout savoir
que les grandes entreprises de plus de
5000 salariés jetables que du prix les
jeux papa du public bien entendu les
grandes entreprises c'est 30 % de
l'emploi donc c'est quand même c est si
on prend ça plus les entreprises de
taille intermédiaire sert de cube 250
séries on arrive à la moitié des voix
donc c'est important je vous interromps
christophe ramaux je vous interromps ont
fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
il est beaucoup plus facile de faire de
la dette le qui sera réglée par nous
plus tard par nos enfants plus tard les
pays les plus pauvres ne rembourseront
pas donc garder une créance dans le
bilan au passé qu'elle sera jamais
remboursé c'est cette même pas hypocrite
ça n'a pas de sens on a pas de
croissance et on a une dette qui ont
d'ailleurs pas la maîtrise de nos têtes
on est effectivement à la main à nos
créanciers
vous appartenez à celui qui me prêtent
de l'argent soit l'état soit une banque
mais vous lui appartenait totalement
pour christine lagarde la patronne de la
bce l'animation de la dette ne serait ce
que partiel est totalement impensable
c'est pas si facile 2 nuls et la dette
et la limite c'est quoi c'est la planche
à billets qui aura en contrepartie
[Musique]
l afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'europe ou les états
unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus au nord proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population
ça l'est beaucoup plus facilement
puisqu'on venait de sortir d'une d'une
épidémie d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
que si on aura affaire à deux épidémies
aussi dangereuse qui est des mollahs et
coronavirus ça pourrait être très très
difficile pour
[Musique]
on continue notre débat sur le monde
d'après le fameux monde d'après avec
françois asselin président de la ceppm
la confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises et avec christophe ramaux
qui est économiste qui fait partie du
collectif des économistes atterrés
on s'est beaucoup demandé au cours de
ces deux mois de confinement si on
allait se remettre à consommer comme
avant on gaspille et on achetait tout et
n'importe quoi at on dit et tout à coup
enfermés chez nous ces dix banques
pourraient finalement consommer moins
d'autres se sont dit ça fait partie des
phrases les plus intéressantes que j'ai
entendu pendant ce confinement
c'est drôle l'économie s'effondre
justement parce qu'on ne consomme que ce
dont on a besoin
voilà une phrase qui fait effectivement
réfléchir alors dans le monde d'après ce
qu'il faudra consommer plus ne serait-ce
que pour rattraper le retard qu'on a
pris pendant ces deux mois et récupérer
des emplois ou est-ce qu'il faudra qu'on
se met moins françois asselin wow vous
savez d'abord c'est pas l'entreprise qui
décide de tout c'est d'abord chacun
d'entre nous qui à chaque fois qu'on
achète quelque chose finalement on pose
un acte responsable
j'étais un petit peu voyez étonné enfin
étonné sans l'être mais voyez la
frontière espagnole s'est ouverte cette
semaine et vous aviez tous ceux qui
achetaient dans les bureaux de tabac
pendant le confinement les français
n'ont pas hésité une seule seconde à
refranchir la frontière pour aller
s'approvisionner
bien sûr à prix beaucoup plus bas en
espagne en produits en alcool ou en
cigarettes
c'est à dire que la pression
du prix ou de la bonne affaire eh bien
nous sommes tous finalement des moutons
de consommateurs à mon avis ça changera
pas par contre on peut se poser
effectivement sur le moyen long terme et
bien comment orienter la consommation et
donc comment orienter notre production
et là je pense qu'effectivement on a des
questions de fond à se poser il comme il
faut donner du sens au capital je pense
qu'il faut aussi donner aussi donner du
sens à la consommation mais vous savez
il ya des évolutions qui sont
intéressantes
quand on voit par exemple comment le
marché du bio et bien croît d'année en
année on sent bien que par rapport à la
consommation beaucoup de français et
c'est pas que je dirais que les français
assez mondial commence un petit pas à se
poser des questions sur doit-on acheter
plus ou acheter mieux
donc il y a encore à mon avis que tout
un champ à explorer et là c'est aussi le
consommateur monsieur tout le monde qui
est un acteur lui même de son avenir
christophe ramaux beaucoup se sont mis à
rêver pendant ces deux mois quand on a
vu qu'on pouvait si facilement arrêter
l'économie mondiale 1 m 1
la moitié de la planète confinées chez
elles que les avions ne décollent plus
que les magasins ferment on se dit après
tout sur veut lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est dans ce
sens là qu'il faut aller vous en faites
partie
non je ne vais pas partie de mon dire de
ce rêve qui souvent rêve de bacchus dix
ans si je puis me permettre
il ya des gens qui ont vu leur revenu
s'effondrer avec la crise qui ont été
obligés de recourir au broc alimentaire
il préférait aller dans des magasins bio
pour manger de qu'on a besoin de
consommer plus de certaines choses
il a besoin de consommer plus de soin
besoin de consommer plus d'éducation et
la prod très important c'est cette
consommation de soins et d'éducation qui
est principalement produit par le public
mais c'est bien de la production
monsieur à cela il faut cesser d'avoir
en tête l'idée qu'il ya d'un côté les
gens du privé qui serait productif et de
l'autre côté les gens du public qui
seraient les improductifs le public
d'abord d'être bien géré
je serais d'accord avec vous là dessus
c'est pas toujours le cas ça va pas 3 ou
d'accord comme le prix des mais ce que
je veux dire donc donc comment dire mais
d'un fonctionnaire le pib dans sa
voix que bébé la contribution au pib des
fonctionnaires
c'est à peu près la même chose que leurs
pas dans vos proies sur cette lente 20%
ça crée de la valeur ajoutée ce qui
change il entra fonctionnaires et cadres
du privé c'est que l'accès aux biens
publics il est gratuit
votre sorte à sa carte bleue à l'entrée
d'un commissariat d'une école d'un
hôpital mais c'est pas gratuit offrant
tension son discours n'a eu la faculté
il faut le payer bien entendu comme tout
travail productif et s'est payée par
l'impôt
mais ce n est donc à pic il ya une part
des prélèvements obligatoires
mais c'est comment dire c'est pas la
plus grande part qui sert à payer
effectivement les services publics la
plus grande part est très bon il ya
thouarcé pour payer les retraites les
allocations chômage d'abord les
retraites mais tout ça soutient la
demande auprès du privé
alors quelles sont les autres
consommations qu'il faut voter pour
l'environnement si on prend au sérieux
les questions environnementales
il ya plein des besoins qu'il faut
satisfaire il faut réduire nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
ça passe par quoi on sait ce qu'il faut
faire la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments
ça suppose là aussi et ça va servir le
privé
c'est un des fonctionnaires qui vont
aller faire la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments par contre ça suppose des
aides publiques massives de qu'on est
bien mais a bien besoin d'une économie
mixte donc la rénovation thermique du
bâti les transports collectifs
le fait de développer des de la
production électrique non carbonées tout
ça ça suppose de des investissements
publics de la dépense publique
articulé bien entendu aux actifs privés
donc là il faut développer toutes ses
consommations toutes ses productions en
revanche à côté il ya bien entendu
et ça je suis toujours pour partir du
principe que y compris quand quelqu'un
qui ne l'est pas d'accord un discours
qui quelque part perse c'est qui met le
doigt sur quelque chose et donc les
histoires de décroissance tout ça c'est
vraiment pas ma tasse de thé je trouve
que c'est vraiment quelque chose de
commentaires de données de profondément
méprisant y compris pour la misère
sociale
quand je dis la misère sociale
avant même la crise celle il ya il ya un
institut qui s'appelle le credoc en
france qui fait des études sur la
consommation des français et bien vous
allez millions personnes aujourd'hui qui
sont en situation de mal logement près
de 10 millions donc ça suppose de
construire il faut construire du
logement qui sont en situation de sous
consommation électrique un pas chauffé
dans l'appartement en hiver parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens de chauffer y
compris quand il ya des enfants donc et
qui aimerait bien manger lieu à ne pas
bouger simplement des pronos de
l'alimentation industrielle misons pas
les moyens d'accéder à 100 donc il ya
plein de besoin cette scène par ok les
vosges - qui pour faire décroître
donc j'ai dit est un sujet
l'obsolescence des produits et c'est là
bien entendu je pense qu'il ya matière
effectivement à avoir un pilotage sur la
il faut revoir la fois l'organisation
d'autres écoles notamment des grandes
entreprises réalité aussi le public a
peut-être ça et reprend les finalités de
l'école
donc il va falloir planifier plus
françois cela planifier plus écoutée
bachelot notre façon on a besoin d'un
état stratège c'est clair si on a
simplement un état qui avance et
malheureusement c'est souvent le cas
mais en fonction des échéances
électorales et bien souvent d'ailleurs
qui ne tient pas ses promesses une fois
les élections gagnées
ça va être très compliqué mais mais mais
là on n'a pas construit à lacets pme on
n'est pas entre guillemets pour moi
d'état on est pour mieux d'état c'est à
dire que l'état de notre point de vue la
sphère publique parce que l'état peut
être la mairie la collectivité le
département la région et bien sûr l'état
et même les établissements publics
l'éducation nationale en font partie on
a besoin d'un pays qui est administrée
bien évidemment on a besoin de former
notre jeunesse donc on a besoin d'une
éducation nationale qui forment bien les
enfants notre pays
on a besoin de missions régaliennes qui
fasse que l'on puisse vivre en sécurité
que ce soit à l'extérieur de nos
frontières pour les protéger comme à
l'intérieur de nos frontières
donc tout ça c'est essentiel pour la
bonne marche de la société et bien
évidemment pour aussi le bon
fonctionnement des entreprises donc du
secteur marchand mais quand nous voyons
par exemple que l'argent investi par
exemple si on prend de vous parler de la
santé investi dans le domaine de la
santé
quand on regarde par rapport aux autres
pays
l'argent qu'ils investissent et qu'on
voit parfois chez nous le résultat est
bien on peut se dire quand même qu'il y
a un vrai souci par rapport à
l'efficacité donc parfois on se dit mais
finalement est-ce que c'est un manque de
moyens ou au contraire un manque
d'efficacité peut-être y at-il un énorme
problème de management au sein de la
sphère publique pour ce manque
d'efficacité et nous avons besoin du
service public comme son nom l'indiqué
il est au service du public et dans des
périodes comme nous traversons et bien
c'est l'homme n'a vraiment besoin que le
public soit à notre service parce qu'il
faut soutenir les acteurs économiques
et c'est là effectivement où l'état avec
ses agents
avec ses fonctionnaires doit remplir ce
rôle d'accompagnement pourquoi parce que
eux le travail qu'ils ne travaillent pas
à savoir s'ils sont en confinement ils
touchent 100 % de leur salaire
c'est pas le cas des salariés du secteur
privé ils retrouveront leur emploi parce
qu'il est sécurisé et nous effectivement
on est dans une zone de risques extrêmes
donc on a besoin de cet état qui nous
soutient mon abonnement au titre de cet
état qui nous accompagnent et c'est là
effectivement ou parfois
eh bien on peut changer entre guillemets
de deux sentiments par rapport à la
sphère privée et la sphère publique sans
que nous soyons ennemis les uns les
autres mais on a parfois l'impression
nouvelle entreprise que nous sommes
finalement des risques tout parfois
entouré parfois enquiquiner de gens qui
risquent rien du tout et on a besoin de
tout le monde alors c'est une caricature
ce que je viens de vous dire mais c'est
quelque chose que nous vivons
profondément tant que chef d'entreprise
et c'est là où parfois on aurait besoin
d'une administration qui nous
accompagnent plutôt qu'uniquement qui
nous contrôle voire nous sanctionne ou
nous ponctionne donc l'efficacité elle
doit être partout aussi bien bien sûr
dans le secteur marchand la situation
nous fait faillite si vous n'êtes pas
efficace mais aussi dans la sphère
publique
on peut être aussi productifs et là je
vous rejoins dans la sphère publique
comme un secteur marchand et ça rend
service à tout le monde au bout du bout
donc le fait effectivement d'avoir un
état stratège qui investit et là je vous
rejoins complètement dans des secteurs
premièrement ou l'investissement va
revenir vous il y aura un vrai retour
sur investissement entre et
l'investissement au niveau du territoire
me semble très important et par exemple
la construction
le logement c'est généralement de
l'investissement qui n'est pas
délocalisable qui fait travailler de la
main d'oeuvre locale et qui en plus
améliore et structurent le pays pour des
années pour des décennies
et si par exemple on lançait dès
maintenant un plan de rénovation
énergétique massif et bien c'est de
l'investissement qui demain serait tout
à fait vertueux puisque on permettrait
de faire des économies en matière de
dépenses énergétiques
il y à un demi siècle il ya eu là
l'épidémie de grippe de hong kong qui en
france a fait 31 mille morts en deux
mois
à l'époque le gouvernement n'a pris
aucune précaution
d'ailleurs personne ne s'est aperçu
qu'il y avait la grippe de hong kong on
ne disait pas tous les soirs au journal
de 20 heures combien il y avait une mort
on ne le disait pas plus en france
qu'aux etats-unis ou ailleurs
personne n'a fait attention à la grippe
de hong kong et personne non plus n'a
porté plainte ensuite ni contre les
gouvernements ni contre les chefs
d'entreprise ni contre qui que ce soit
on s'est au contraire des péchés
d'oublier qu'ils avaient eu cette grippe
que personne n'avait remarqué
aujourd'hui c'est exactement le
contraire on n'avait jamais pris autant
de précautions pour une pandémie quelle
qu'elle soit et les plaintes fleurissent
alors on devient de plus en plus
procéduriers mais dans le monde d'après
est-ce qu'il va falloir plus de
responsabilité pénale
vis-à-vis de nos dirigeants y compris
des dirigeants d'entreprise ou moins
françois reste un bon vous savez la
responsabilité n'a fait que s'accroître
au fil des ans
quand vous êtes chef d'entreprise
heureusement vous ne savez pas tout
parce que vous avez plus de 60
incrimination pénale spécifique
potentiel sur vos épaules
il faut bien admettre que notre société
est complexe et que avec l'évolution de
ces complexités on parlait de la
financiarisation les de la société de
l'économie
eh bien elle sait aussi énormément
judiciariser et nous sommes tous autant
coupables que victime pourquoi parce que
si demain il vous arrive quelque chose
ou quelque chose à l'un de vos proches
un enfant vous aurez immédiatement la
tendance de vous dire mais sait-il
responsable et vous allez demander
réparation et c'est un sentiment tout à
fait naturel sauf que poussé à l'excès
eh bien ça pose de vrais problèmes
d'exercice du pouvoir
parce que lorsque vous devez lorsque
vous devez les responsables de tous et
de ce qui vous échappe
eh bien comment faites vous pour prendre
des décisions en confiance mais le cas
effectivement nicoby de 19 est un cas
d'école quelque part pourquoi parce que
quand vous avez un risque professionnel
comme son nom l'indiqué sa touche votre
profession donc vous le comprenez et
vous pouvait l'anticiper et donc vous
pouvez l'éviter
lorsque ça touche un risque sanitaire
c'est lié à la santé là quelque part moi
mon métier c'est pas d'être médecin donc
ça m'échappe
et quand bien même je mets en place tous
les moyens pour éviter que dans mon
entreprise quelqu'un attrape la maladie
je n'en suis pas sûr à 100%
or si le droit du travail vous obliger à
une obligation de moyens renforcés
le droit pénal est bien peu se retourner
contre vous si demain à salarier attrape
la maladie et que lui même ou un de ses
ayants droit si pas grand malheur il
décéda et bien demander réparation
auprès de son employeur est là même si
au bout du bout vous avez très peu de
chances d'être condamnée parce que
faudra encore prouvé que s'arrêter dans
l'entreprise que le salarié attrapé la
maladie
et bien vous allez suivre un chemin
initiatique qui est terrible donc il
faut pouvoir sans s'affranchir de sa
responsabilité pouvoir assurer et
assumer toutes ses responsabilités et
finalement nous chefs d'entreprise on
aime ça prend nos responsabilités et on
est fait pour ça comme ma mère
d'ailleurs comme un directeur d'école
mais encore faut-il assumer notre
responsabilité toute notre
responsabilité n'est pas celle qui
finalement nous échappe donc avec
l'accord qui a trouvé le compromis entre
l'exécutif et le sénat finalement on
rappelle un petit peu le droit commun la
loi qui dit que finalement s'il n'y a
pas de faute intentionnelle
et bien c'est quand même compliqué
d'aller poursuivre un responsable qu'ils
soient élus qu'ils soient le chef
d'entreprise au pénal parce que il y
aura fait toute la diligence en
connaissance de cause qu'il fallait pour
éviter la catastrophe
mais malheureusement et bien c'est
arrivé plus ou moins de responsabilité
pénale pour nos dirigeants
vous savez je travaille un peu sur
l'état social sur l'idée qu'au xxème
siècle on a eu une véritable révolution
convainc supporte hôtel avec la
protection sociale les services publics
droit du travail des politiques
économiques budgétaires monétaires et
l'origine de cet état social en france
me retrouve seigneur c'est la loi de
1898 sur les accidents du travail
je vais répondre à une question à vous
allez voir qu'est ce que dit cette loi
au début du 19e siècle c'était le code
civil qui prévalait et donc quand la
brique tombé sur la tête de l'ouvrier on
disait ben c'est à cause de l'ouvrier il
fallait qu'il fasse car au milieu du 19e
siècle
il ya eu un changement de jurisprudence
qui a dit maintien si l'ouvrier avait
démontré que si la brique est tombé sur
sa tête
c'est à cause de son patron eh bien il
peut se retourner contre son patron la
plupart du temps ils sont retournés pas
y avoir demain
mais bref mais dans les secteurs à
risques des mines les chemins de fer il
y avait beaucoup d'accidents eh bien
vous savez quoi
c'est le grand patronat des secteurs à
risque qu'a dit il faut sortir de ce
registre de responsabilité individuelle
et ces cancers qu'on a créé la loi de
1898 sont les accidents du travail qui
dit que si la brique est tombé sur la
tête de l'ouvrier c'est pas à cause de
lui c'est pas cool du patron c'est pas
parce qu'il lui a acheté dessus d'un
ciblage dessus il ya toujours le cas
suite et de recours au pénal mais c'est
parce qu'elle est tombée c'est le risque
de la production en commun et donc comme
inscrit dans le droit la notion de
risque social et de responsabilité
sociale c'est de responsabilité de la
société
donc moi je suis toujours circonspect
quand on en revient à des logis de mise
en cause de responsabilité individuelle
lahoud c'est la responsabilité sociale
qui est qui est en jeu
voilà il faut savoir qu'à la fin du
19ème les libéraux étaient contre cette
loi de 1898 sur le thème mais vous êtes
en train d'inscrire dans le droit que la
société ce n'est pas qu'une somme
d'individus de responsabilité
individuelle
vous êtes en train d'inscrire dans le
droit que la société une consistance
propres qu'elles y a qu'a les risques
sociaux une responsabilité sociale
mais vous allez nous conduire au
socialisme il
il n'avait pas tort de l'aube de leur
point de vue c'est ce qu'on a fait on a
dit ben y'a pas que les actionnent il ya
là et la famille ta ta ta ta ta ta et on
arrive à la situation actuelle où c'est
un chiffre auquel peu connu il faut
savoir qu'on a le goût font pas comment
dire quand vous additionnez des
prestations sociales en espèces et à
lire les retraites principalement mais
aussi les allocations familiales
allocations chômage puis ce qu'on
appelle les transferts sociaux en nature
voilà la consommation de soins
socialiser une éducation vous
additionnez tous à vous arrivez à 818
milliards
c'est le shield 2018 ses supérieurs
c'est plus plus important que la somme
des salaires nets niveau dans d économie
mixte alors vous êtes bien s'être aussi
insolent la tête veut dire c'est trop il
et les retraités font pour les faire
vivre
et quand on les fait vivre avec les
privés par le privé avec des fonds par
capitalisation c'est plus inégalitaire
et généralement c'est plus coûteux la
santé il faut bien assurer qu ans est
assuré par le privé les états unis mais
ce que je veux dire c'est une
catastrophe
petite parenthèse sur son cousin dit
tout à l'heure on a fait de l'austérité
quand même en matière de santé et
présida les courses mais la dépense
d'investissement des hôpitaux publics a
baissé de moitié en pourcentage dans la
recette entre 2,9 et est aujourd'hui
donc il ya une austérité on l'a payé au
prix fort la raison pour laquelle
l'allemagne s'en est mieux sorti c'est
qu'en l'espèce parce qu'il ya un point
des lander ya pas de ce que vous appelez
parfois le corporatif qui fait qu'il ya
plein de candeur de collectivités
locales conduis moi je veux pas qu'on
ferme en hôpital et donc d'aller plus de
lits en réanimation et donc ils ont été
plus en mesure d'amortir le choc
ce choc et puis par ailleurs l'allemagne
comme on dirait une politique
industrielle c'est comme ça d'ailleurs
qu'elle a construit historiquement sont
l'industrie avec ni compris en soutien
public extrêmement fort bismarck et c
est donc à était pas billy en matière de
politique industrielle
bacon produire des tests ou pour
produire des masses nous qu'il faut
aller jusqu'au dans la façon dont on
tire les leçons de ces scripts de self
il faut il faut faire une relance à la
fois verte et m'occupe soeur et sociales
et sociale c'est à dire que il faut
remonter bien aujourd'hui les mains
sales
il faut réduire c'est votre rémunération
complètement exorbitantes qui existe
chez lui chez les grands patrons et
notamment du cac 40 c'est complètement
aberrant
donc il faut il faut une société plus
égalitaire
j'éteins dit complètement égalitarisme
et plus il est vital il faut donc une
relance à la fois écologiste et sociale
et je pense qu autour de ça on peut
quand même avoir un beau projet commun
de société offrira tous compris on crée
des emplois utiles et d'ailleurs ce sera
la dernière question françois asselin
faut-il s'affranchir de certaines règles
environnementales ou sociales comme le
demandent certains y compris des
syndicats patronaux pas le vôtre mais
mais d'autres s'affranchir carrément
parce que pour la relance là c'est
absolument nécessaire ou au contraire
comme christophe ramaux l'demande
renforcer les règles environnementales
et sociales
alors vous savez c'est sonné pour
l'économie de marché on n'est pas pour
la loi de la jungle donc n'allons pas à
travers les deux que nous traversons
d'un seul coup balayer tous les essais
d'économie vertueuse qui timidement
essaie d'imprimer à la société moi je
pense que ce qu'il faut c'est tout
simplement faire en sorte vous l'avez
très bien lire monsieur rameau que s'il
ya de l'investissement et la stratégie
de l'état à investir que ça aille vers
des secteurs qui fait que dément sur
soie verte ou si demain on donne
voilà une prime à la casse pour relancer
l'automobile que ça aille vers des
véhicules plus tôt vers qui polluent
mois si on doit relancer un plan de
rénovation énergétique
c'est un investissement tout à fait
intelligent et nous ce que nous disons
la cpmc que si on doit faire un plan de
relance
il faut d'abord quand il doit reposer
sur trois critères
premièrement qu'on pense à l'économie
circulaire pour nous c'est un
intéressant que l'investissement est
bien il retourne à celui qui investit
donc que l'investissement soit liée au
territoire région à la nation alors hein
deuxièmement il faut que
l'investissement aille vers des secteurs
qui produisent beaucoup de main d'oeuvre
en clair vaut mieux faire travailler
beaucoup de français que donner du
pouvoir d'achat pour faire un porte d'un
portage
on de produits fabriqués en asie par
exemple et puis troisièmement il faut
que cet investissement à terme et bien
produisent des économies pour le pays et
c'est là où la transition énergétique et
écologique peut être très intéressante
est là et bien effectivement je vais
faire plaisir à monsieur rameau l'état
peut y aller franchement pour investir
parce que là ça sera de l'investissement
productif
pour le reste il me semble qu'à un
moment ou un autre il faudra avoir un
retour sur investissement et redonner ou
rééquilibrer l'état qui aura pas me
semble-t-il besoin aussi de recettes
pour assurer et bien la qualité du
service social qu'on doit nos
concitoyens il nous reste il nous reste
quatre minutes on s'est dit que dans ce
monde d'après hypothétique bien entendu
ce que devait faire l'état ce que devait
faire les entreprises
ce que devraient faire les actionnaires
on ne s'est pas dit ce que devait faire
les individus alors en quoi est-ce que
nous sommes censés nous aussi individus
quel que soit notre activité
professionnelle citoyens en quoi
devons-nous chargé de munich n'ont pas
dominé par d'autres christophe pourvoir
pour répondre rapidement mal temps
imparti je pense que je suis je suis
d'accord il peut sua cela le public ça
sera l'état où les collectivités locales
doit être bien gérée et sata iii s'est
pas toujours le cas
je suis continuellement d'accord avec
vous une fois qu'on a dit ça je pense
que ce qui serait recréer société sqy la
sortie de cette crise ou voir à quel
point nous avons besoin d'hôpitaux des
bois etc
eh bien je pense que il faut se dire que
il faut remettre en cause la délibéré
miss la finance libéralisée le libre
échange vous êtes quasiment d'accord sur
ce point
et ensuite il faut se dire que pour bien
vivre il faut payer des impôts et
cotisent et dans la bonne humeur ça tout
ça soit bien géré mais il faut payer les
impôts et cotisent heures à 10 heures
alors bien entendu ça suppose de talent
et de remettre un peu de justice fiscale
d'accord donc bien entendu le b à ba
c'est vrai
tabbee s r c'est de créer c'est en
discussion actuellement de recréer une
tranche permet à paul aider les plus
élevés je dis bien les plus élevés donc
donc voilà donc la halle à cet effet
suite à la crise de 2008 s'est compris
aux états unis c'était des rôles du
titre pérot mutu aux états unis mais
voilà je pense que là il ya les moyens
de je pense que l'enjeu c'est de refaire
société y compris refaire société
d'entre ceux du public ceux du privé et
on a besoin du privé et ceux du public
je pense que là il ya vraiment besoin de
refaire société redessiné un désir
d'émancipation des jours heureux
comme disait notre président à lui dans
ce dans ce sens là jamais mais n'est pas
simplement des effets de manche il a
retrouvé l'esprit du d'esprit réel du
programme du conseil national de la
résistance allemande et rubin esquisse
de réponse de christophe ramaux il
faudra payer plus d'impôts mais
seulement les riches mais même question
en tant qu'individu en quoi va-t-il
falloir changer nous aussi dans ce monde
d'après et qui est pas seulement l'état
les entreprises et les actionnaires
qu'ils soient obligés de faire leur
propre révolution
alors moi je pense qu'il faut il ne faut
pas croire au miroir aux alouettes c'est
à dire que il a je rejoins christophe
ramaux c'est à dire que la décroissance
mais frais puisque autre chose parce que
décroître moi je me dis c'est s'y
arrêter de vivre donc c'est mourir par
contre je pense que on peut se poser la
question d'une certaine sobriété
voilà c'est à dire que faire en sorte
que les actes que l'on pose est bien
permettre d'assurer la pérennité et
finalement le fait que lorsque j'aurai
fini moi mon parcours sur terre et bien
la génération montante pourra se dire je
suis fier de mon grand père
parce que finalement il a pas gaspiller
ce que moi je vais faire avec beaucoup
d'attention que j'ai essayé de conserver
et préserver comme il l'a fait avec
beaucoup d'attention
moi ça me semblait question de fond qui
devrait nous habiter dans notre manière
de vivre donc dans notre manière de
consommer et d'acheter donc ça veut dire
aussi moins s'endetter parce que sinon
ce sont nos enfants nos petits enfants
qui paieront sa dette
et bien sûr c'est pour ça que vous voyez
dans la réforme des retraites
moi j'étais très très bon ceux qui
prônaient le
augmentation des cotisations y compris
pour les salariés je me dis mais si c
d'augmentation des cotisations me perds
m me permet à moi de partir plus tôt en
retraite et je vais rester quelque part
un fardeau à mes enfants petits enfants
qui eux devront et bien partir plus tard
parce que nous nous sommes partis plutôt
comme c'est par répartition eh bien je
me dis mais est ce que est ce qu'on
n'est pas en train de préparer une
guerre des générations
donc je pense que on doit me semble-t-il
notre génération en tout cas la mienne
j'ai 55 ans peut-être se dire le peu de
temps où le beaucoup de temps qui nous
reste à vivre bien faisons en sorte que
d'une part on laisse une planète en
meilleur état que ce que nous l'avons
nous même connu quand nous sommes menés
et peut-être aussi un état de notre pays
plus paisible qui tout simplement me
permet d'espérer nous avons et nous
devons aimer notre avenir
merci tous les deux d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]